I can confirm we have offices working
around the clock and we have now
arrested a full person a 48 year old man
from Northern Ireland was arrested at
Stansted Airport earlier today on
suspicion of conspiracy to traffic
people and on suspicion of manslaughter
it follows the arrest of a 38 year old
man and a 38 year old woman from
Warrington during warrants executed in
Cheshire overnight they are currently in
custody
also on suspicion of conspiracy to
traffic people and on suspicion of
manslaughter a 25 year old man arrested
on Wednesday on suspicion of murder
remains in custody we are working
closely with the National Crime Agency
the Home Office the Foreign and
Commonwealth Office border force and
immigration enforcement we have begun
the process of transporting the victims
from the port of tilbury to the mortuary
from field hospital formal
identification processes will take place
as well as the examinations to establish
the causes of their deaths this process
is likely to be a lengthy one but it is
crucial and we're working with her
Majesty's coroner to ensure the dignity
of the victims and the respect for their
loved ones is at the forefront of our
investigation I'm acutely aware of the
international interest in this case and
the appetite for information and we will
provide more updates as and when we can